so when the lead actor in Wonka song
auditioned for along the roadside can
you tell us how that came about and did
you have any idea when he reached out to
you what's happened with following me
have I I was tipped off like here's the
guy he email introduction you know I
think he'll be a good pick for the part
we run the you know kind of closing
stages of casting an actor for that part
who has not to do with YouTube Hollywood
guayabera movies you know and we're
talking to his agent about contract and
working in a lot laundry and dry
cleaning into contract and that's
exactly what you know my point is like
you did with these people nothing
against all the factors but you know
it's it's it's tricky and then I have a
guy who says look I've half a million
people on my channel almost and you know
here's the audition I would really like
to audition for I have to be part of
this film and of course you know you
listen and then once they saw how badly
he wanted me to film and the potential
of him and you know I would never know
in the retrospect I don't see well
school but specialist is so many people
who saw the film in Europe and here love
his performance and he's so different
than what he doesn't YouTube I mean he's
I think most of the people know who he
is it's like you know the Obama
impersonator guy like we all kind of at
some point heard I heard about him
before I knew that that's why he that's
him auditioning for the part I saw you
know Obama clips online yeah I know
that's him he transforms but it's really
it's funny and what's interesting about
emailing back and forth it's almost a
test for you and probably for him as
well to kind of see different things
because you can learn a lot from someone
from just email exchanges over time
you're not fast they get back to how
responsive they are to what you asked
for
yes yes says dad and first time we met
we all we did was talk for like eight
hours just walking up and down the beach
you know it wasn't you know okay can you
play the part and we just started
talking
and you know he opened up about a lot of
things and it's good to establish some
sort of trust off the bat and it's I
don't know it becomes less professional
and more personal and I think that's who
you want on Saturn alone in the movie
where the food will be horrible
sleeping ranges would be pretty bad it's
gonna be intense it's gonna be hell and
that's what you want to be part of that
crew I mean one of the people that would
have been a DP on the film is you were
now on DP but I thought this is they
wouldn't I don't know like you know how
you bring them pizza five days straight
in a row for lunch
you know it's yeah you need people who
who are I don't know who want to take
the bullet so it's almost like you have
to look at who you're casting not to
start they talented but can you have
almost a relationship with this person
because it really is I mean you're
getting into a a year to three year long
relationship that was the thing we
decided with the German actress our
leaders a German actress we flew her in
from Germany and when we sent out the
script or casting agent in Germany we
got a really good response we got
editions from actresses than one Berlin
camera 2012 and Berlin Film Fest all the
good actresses with producers who come
with money but that was the thing like
all these requests you know it's okay
this is a and this little German actress
was great and is great Angelina she's a
theater actress in Hamburg and she's
just trooper like I'll sleep with
somebody's couch no problems for a month
yeah all that and you know again we just
spoke yesterday and we can't wait to
bring her here at a festival do you have
any tests and tests that you throw out
people's way to kind of see is this
going to work because it's not you know
one of the things the regarding on
Jelena was this one actress auditioned
and you know economically she's a
smarter choice because of I don't know
all these things that then you would get
as far as distribution marketing but
then as
started contemplating idea of saying
sorry to Angelina if I had to I started
breaking down like I can't do this she's
so lovable you know and that's exactly
what I needed for the character in the
film because it has to do with that's
the story looking and I was like nah
forget we just want to stick with
Angelina because I want people to feel
the way I felt you can't say no to this
person right yeah it shows
you